Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde".
Les profiteurs de l'Afrique,
de quoi s'agit-il ?
L'Afrique participe
de la mondialisation,
tout comme les autres continents.
Elle ne manque pas d'atouts
pour être un aiguillon
du progrès
et du développement.
Une démographie vigoureuse
et jeune,
des richesses minières
et énergétiques,
une classe moyenne qui consomme,
une croissance soutenue,
mais elle n'en profite pas
à la mesure
de ses richesses
pour des raisons intérieures,
parce que ce continent est
sans cesse précarisé
par des conflits violents,
le terrorisme et une corruption
endémique,
mais aussi et surtout,
selon la majorité
des observateurs africains,
voire occidentaux,
parce que ce continent
n'est pas protagoniste
de son destin.
Selon le pape François,
au cours d'un récent déplacement
en République démocratique
du Congo,
l'Afrique subirait toujours
les effets délétères
- je le cite -
d'un colonialisme économique
déchaîné.
Sont incriminés,
pêle-mêle,
les drastiques ajustements
structurels du FMI,
de la Banque mondiale, de l'OMC,
les pressions de la Chine,
de la Russie,
de l'Europe,
le pillage des ressources,
le soutien des dictateurs,
l'ingérence
dans les affaires intérieures.
Bref,
l'Afrique cherche à conquérir
une légitime souveraineté
pour agir face aux enjeux
économiques, sociaux,
climatiques et stratégiques
qui agitent
la planète.
Pour en parler
et discerner qui sont
ces profiteurs de l'Afrique,
nous le ferons
avec mes invités
que je vous présente.
Nous avons
Mme Aminata Dramane Traoré
qui est en visioconférence
depuis le Mali.
Je rappelle, Mme Traoré,
que vous êtes ancienne ministre
de la Culture
et du Tourisme du Mali.
Vous êtes également essayiste.
Sylvie Brunel,
vous êtes professeur
des universités.
Calixthe Beyala,
vous êtes romancière.
Antoine Glaser,
vous êtes journaliste et essayiste.
Vous venez de voir
cette citation du pape François
qui dit :
"Cessez d'étouffer
"l'Afrique :
elle n'est pas une mine à exploiter
"et une terre à dévaliser."
D'après les statistiques
et autres projections,
tant internationales qu'africaines,
l'Afrique connaît
un développement certain
et des avancées
conséquentes,
de l'espérance de vie
aux autres indicateurs
du développement humain,
qu'il s'agisse de la santé,
de l'éducation, du niveau de vie.
Pourquoi cette image persistante
de prédation,
de pillage des ressources,
de corruption croissante,
bref, de mal-développement ?
Calixthe Beyala.
-Ecoutez, je tenais d'abord
à saluer Aminata.
Vraiment, mais vraiment.
Salut.
Cela est dû,
essentiellement, d'abord,
à l'histoire de l'esclavage,
à l'histoire coloniale aussi.
Quand un peuple a été,
pendant des siècles,
aussi maltraité, méprisé,
écrasé, étouffé...
N'oubliez surtout pas que,
durant ces périodes,
tous les hommes brillants
ont été systématiquement
soit déportés,
soit assassinés.
L'Afrique s'est retrouvée,
à un moment donné,
très démunie.
Tous les Kwame Nkrumah sont
retrouvés morts en exil,
les Um Nyobe...
Tous ces hommes
qui portaient l'Afrique
- vous savez,
toutes les sociétés ont besoin
de figures fortes
pour avancer -
ont été décimés.
On a laissé les plus fragiles.
Ceux qui demandaient
le moins l'indépendance,
on les a mis au pouvoir.
Les plus faibles
parmi nous,
on les a mis au pouvoir
pour pouvoir mieux les contrôler,
mieux exploiter l'Afrique,
mieux tuer les Africains,
d'ailleurs, parce que
nous sommes pris
par ces organisations mondiales
dont vous parlez,
qui nous exploitent,
mais aussi
- ça dépend des pays, d'ailleurs -
en Afrique centrale,
par nos propres dictateurs,
nos propres frères qui nous mettent
dans une situation difficile.
Depuis les ajustements
structurels...
-On va rentrer dans le détail.
Je voulais juste
une première impression.
Vous aurez l'occasion
de détailler les différents points.
Mme Traoré,
une première impression
sur cette question-là,
ce mal-développement
malgré les atouts.
Une première impression.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
*-Moi, je doute,
d'abord.
Je me pose des questions
sur ce que...
ce développement veut dire.
Quand vous dites que
l'Afrique est
dans la mondialisation
au même titre que les autres
et que j'entends parler
d'un certain nombre
d'indicateurs,
l'idée consiste à dire
de toute façon
que la mondialisation
est un marché et aurait tiré
- en tout cas,
en ce qui concerne le Sud global -
bon nombre de gens de la pauvreté,
et ainsi de suite.
Soyons réalistes.
Prenons le pouls
du monde,
au moment où je vous parle,
d'où vous me parlez
et d'où je vous parle.
J'ai l'intime conviction
que la mondialisation heureuse
est une sorte de chimère
et que, chez nous,
de toute façon,
la décolonisation
est restée inachevée.
Nous sommes des pays
sous tutelle.
Immédiatement
après l'accession
à ce que nous avons cru
être l'indépendance,
on a emboîté le pas...
En fait, on n'a pas su rompre
avec un système économique
destructeur, prédateur,
ce qui est lié à la nature
du système global.
-Vous incriminez
le système global.
Vous en pensez quoi,
Sylvie Brunel,
de cette image
un peu déconsidérée de l'Afrique,
malgré les atouts
et le développement ?
-Un fait est certain :
les marchands,
militaires et missionnaires
qui fondaient
la colonisation de l'Afrique
sont toujours à l'oeuvre
dans les Afrique.
Ils prennent d'autres formes,
mais ce sont toujours des marchands,
militaires et missionnaires
omniprésents dans les 54 pays
d'Afrique, et quand on regarde...
-Vous voulez dire
qu'il y a
un continuum colonial ?
-Oui, mais il a changé de nature.
Les profiteurs de l'Afrique
sont aujourd'hui
extrêmement nombreux,
à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur.
C'est ça, le comble.
Ce continent qui est formé
de forces vives
extrêmement marquantes
et qui pourrait apprendre
au reste du monde
ce que sont
le développement durable,
la résilience,
l'économie
de l'ensemble des matières,
la relation
avec la nature, cette vitalité,
eh bien, ce continent continue
d'être en queue des indicateurs
de développement.
J'en veux pour preuve
quelque chose qui me marque :
le taux de mortalité infantile.
C'est un bon révélateur
de la situation d'un pays.
C'est le nombre d'enfants
qui meurent avant l'âge d'un an
pour 1000 naissances vivantes.
La moyenne mondiale est
de 28 pour 1000.
Elle a beaucoup baissé.
On est vraiment dans une évolution
qui est très encourageante,
mais en Afrique,
c'est toujours presque le double.
Ce continent africain,
c'est un continent riche,
peuplé de pauvres
qui se battent
au quotidien pour leur survie,
avec des dirigeants
qui ne font pas ce qu'il faudrait
pour aider leur peuple.
-Et vous,
Antoine Glaser ?
-Pour poursuivre un peu,
je pense que c'est surtout
une sorte de substitution,
je veux dire,
en dehors
d'un certain nombre d'acteurs
qui sont toujours présents.
Ce qui m'a vraiment surpris
- bien sûr, j'ai plus connu
la période postcoloniale -
c'est à quel point,
finalement,
des personnalités
dans tous les secteurs,
et moi-même...
Je me considère
comme un profiteur de l'Afrique.
En tant que journaliste
spécialiste de l'Afrique,
j'ai pu, pendant 30 ans,
faire des bouquins.
Mes petites publications
avaient un retentissement,
parce que mes confrères
africains
et français d'origine africaine
n'étaient pas pris au sérieux
en France
ou étaient sous la pression
des autocrates dans leur pays.
Je balaye devant ma porte.
J'ai connu
la substitution.
Ca a été l'enseignement.
Tout le domaine de l'enseignement,
pendant 30 ans,
c'était des dizaines
de milliers de Français
qui faisaient la coopération.
Je ne critique pas leur travail,
mais j'ai vu des rapports
du ministère de la Coopération.
En 89-90 encore, ils ont dit :
"Arrêtons, parce que, là,
"sur 5000 coopérants,
il y en a 70
"qui sont des enseignants
et qui font à la place
"des Africains."
Si on ne comprend pas
qu'il faut arrêter
de se substituer
aux Africains,
pas simplement
leur donner des leçons,
mais faire à leur place...
Et puis, la deuxième chose...
A un moment donné,
il faut comprendre
qu'il y a une période
où il faut arrêter
de faire "à la place de"
et apprendre de l'Afrique.
On n'a pas appris de l'Afrique.
On a exporté,
dans tous nos pays,
pas juste une Constitution
ou notre langue,
mais notre façon de faire.
-Aminata Traoré,
je voudrais vous poser
une question qui peut paraître
provocante et délicate,
mais j'aimerais avoir
votre avis.
L'Afrique se veut de plain-pied
dans le monde,
même si vous dites que
la mondialisation est malheureuse.
Elle est quand même
pleinement active,
parce que
c'est une forte population
avec des ressources,
une activité,
mais elle est toujours
à la recherche
d'une aide au développement.
La question que je vous pose
- et c'est à vous que je la pose,
parce que vous avez exercé
des responsabilités politiques -
c'est : comment on peut assumer
un destin souverainement,
tout en restant dépendant
du reste du monde ?
-Moi, d'abord,
je voudrais que l'on fasse
la distinction
entre un profiteur de l'extérieur
et un profiteur de l'intérieur.
Je crois que, pour...
Il faut inscrire l'Afrique
dans le monde.
Il n'y a pas...
Il y a des spécificités africaines.
C'est une histoire singulière,
pour les raisons
que Calixthe a évoquées,
mais, moi, je me dis que
les responsabilités...
Je peux pas dire que...
Le FMI,
la Banque mondiale...
Toutes ces institutions
financières, monétaires...
C'est des relations
de dominant à dominé.
Ca a toujours été ça.
De la traite négrière à ce jour,
le système capitaliste
a toujours eu besoin
des richesses du continent,
en hommes, les esclaves,
en ressources naturelles.
Rien n'a changé.
Quand je réfléchis...
J'ai regardé ce matin la situation
de la dette africaine.
Nous nous sommes endettés
en mettant en place
des infrastructures
dont les grandes entreprises
étrangères
avaient besoin et ont besoin.
On rembourse,
aujourd'hui.
Vous dites que j'ai été au pouvoir.
J'ai été ministre de la Culture
et du Tourisme.
Je sais de près
que l'Afrique n'a pas eu
que des dictateurs,
que des corrompus.
Les dirigeants n'ont pas
de marge de manoeuvre,
car les décisions
se prennent ailleurs.
Ca, c'est pas spécifique
à l'Afrique.
-Oui, mais...
-Je connais bien...
-Mme Traoré, sur la question
de la dépendance,
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
un problème ?
Etre à la fois dépendant
et vouloir être souverain,
c'est quand même...
Les gens s'interrogent
à ce sujet-là.
-Mais l'Afrique n'a pas choisi
d'être dépendante.
On a créé cette dépendance.
Quand nous étions
à la sortie de ce...
Quand nous avons cru échapper
au joug colonial,
qu'est-ce que
nous avons fait ?
Nous avons continué
la même culture de rentes,
ce que Samir Amin appelle
"l'échange inégal".
L'échange inégal a prévalu
et continue.
Nous ne décidons pas
du prix des matières premières.
Quand on connaît
le processus
de l'endettement,
on a été...
Je ne suis pas
dans la victimisation,
mais c'est clair que
le fardeau de la dette,
la manière
dont le commerce mondial
est structuré et géré,
c'est un système de pillage
de l'Afrique,
et pas du fait des Africains.
C'est pas le choix
des Africains.
-Calixthe Beyala,
pour poursuivre le débat,
j'aimerais avoir votre avis.
L'Afrique, ce sont des Afrique
et de nombreux pays
africains.
Comment expliquer que
certains se débrouillent mieux
que d'autres,
à la fois au niveau
de l'éducation,
du système de santé,
voire du produit
national brut ?
Comment vous expliquez
cette différence
entre les économies
et les sociétés en Afrique ?
-Avant de répondre, je voudrais
revenir sur quelque chose.
Vous avez parlé
de dépendance de l'Afrique,
mais, aujourd'hui,
nous sommes tous interdépendants.
L'Afrique dépend de l'Occident,
qui dépend de l'Afrique
et de l'Asie.
Nous sommes interconnectés
à des degrés divers,
mais, aujourd'hui,
personne n'est totalement autonome.
Il faut arrêter.
Non, non.
-L'aide au développement
ne concerne pas
tous les pays.
-Mais vous pouvez la récupérer,
votre aide
au développement !
Vous envoyez
de l'aide à des dictateurs
et vous dites aider les Africains ?
Personne ne nous aide.
Je tiens à le signaler.
Deuxième chose :
la jeunesse africaine
est devenue
très digne.
Elle n'est pas en train
de quémander.
Même s'il y a quelques gamins
qui traversent la mer
pour survivre,
l'Afrique n'a jamais été
aussi digne
qu'à l'heure actuelle.
Je tiens à le dire.
Nous ne sommes pas
des mendiants.
La jeunesse africaine a conscience,
aujourd'hui,
qu'elle a des matières premières,
qu'elle est riche,
qu'elle peut se développer.
Nous sommes sur un autre...
Enfin, un autre schéma.
Beaucoup de choses ont changé.
Je vais répondre
à votre question.
Certains pays sont
plus avancés que d'autres,
parce qu'ils ont eu
des meilleurs dirigeants.
Ils ont eu des meilleurs dirigeants,
notamment au Ghana,
avec les Rawlings
qui ont quand même éliminé
- on a beau dire ce qu'on veut -
tous les corrompus
et qui ont permis que
le peu qu'ils avaient
- malgré ce que la Banque mondiale
et le FMI faisaient -
servait à éduquer leur peuple,
à le scolariser
et à le soigner.
Par exemple, en Afrique centrale,
on a eu des bouffons.
Il faut se dire la vérité.
Au Cameroun,
au Gabon
ou en Centrafrique,
on a eu des sanguinaires,
des gens qui étaient là,
qui pillaient tout,
qui volaient tout,
qui ne se sont pas souciés
de leur peuple.
Il y a cette responsabilité
qui est là.
Je ne suis pas toujours
en train de dire
que la responsabilité
est ailleurs.
Quelquefois,
on peut nourrir sa famille
avec peu.
On peut avoir le sens du partage.
Beaucoup d'Africains aussi,
comme leurs maîtres européens,
n'ont pas eu le sens du partage,
du vivre-ensemble,
de donner un peu à l'autre.
Il y a une responsabilité partagée.
Moi, au fil des années,
quand j'avance dans la vie,
je trouve qu'il n'y a pas
quelqu'un qui ressemble plus
à un homme
qu'un autre homme,
quelle que soit sa couleur.
Ils se ressemblent.
Les capitalistes
les pires dans le monde,
franchement,
j'ai trop vieilli pour penser
qu'ils sont d'un côté
et pas de l'autre.
-Antoine Glaser,
vous qui avez crapahuté,
si je puis dire,
dans beaucoup de pays africains
et depuis
si longtemps,
comment vous expliquez
cette différence
de niveau économique
entre les pays
africains ?
-D'abord,
c'est vrai qu'on est toujours obligé
de parler de la diversité.
Vous avez
un certain nombre de pays
qui ont mené
des mouvements de libération,
que ce soit l'Afrique du Sud,
l'Algérie ou autre.
Ils ne demandent pas à avoir
des cadres de l'extérieur
ou, alors, il y a une aide,
mais c'est vraiment différent
que des pays
qui ont vraiment vécu une période
dans un cocon postcolonial,
pour faire court,
qu'on appelle la Françafrique.
Encore une fois,
pour moi, avec le recul,
c'est vraiment ce truc
de faire à la place des Africains,
de pas laisser, finalement,
pendant longtemps...
On parle, actuellement,
des changements
- Emmanuel Macron -
des nouvelles stratégies africaines
vis-à-vis de l'armée
qui a été humiliée au Mali
et au Burkina Faso.
Moi, j'ai connu pendant 30 ans,
pas simplement parce que la France
le voulait, mais parce que
les chefs d'Etat préféraient
que l'armée française ne forme pas
leurs propres militaires,
parce qu'ils craignaient
les coups d'Etat...
-Ca, vous l'avez dit.
-Voilà les profiteurs.
-Très bien,
mais l'asymétrie économique
entre les différents pays...
-Quand vous avez un pays
comme le Gabon
où va se rendre Emmanuel Macron...
Il y a un million d'habitants.
Il y a des richesses incroyables.
Il y a eu de l'uranium.
Il y encore du manganèse,
du pétrole.
Si c'était bien géré,
ça devrait poser aucun problème.
Vous ne pouvez pas
comparer ça
avec le Nigéria
qui fait des élections...
Elles sont peut-être pas honnêtes,
mais il y a une vraie démocratie
avec des élections.
Il y a 200 millions d'habitants.
Il y en aura 400 millions
en 2050.
Ca sera...
Vous vous rendez compte
qu'il y aura un habitant sur Terre
sur quatre qui sera africain ?
On peut pas comparer.
La seule chose
qu'il faut se rappeler,
c'est que c'est vraiment le moment
pour que... Voilà.
C'est aux Africains...
"L'Afrique aux Africains",
c'est pas qu'un mot.
On va pas continuer
à faire à leur place.
Quand je dis
"Qu'ils se démerdent",
tout le monde dit "Non".
-Sylvie Brunel,
j'aimerais avoir
votre avis,
à partir de ce qui a été dit.
De ce qui a été dit
sur cette différence
de développement,
est-ce qu'il vous paraît
illusoire
qu'un jour il y ait
un marché économique,
une union africaine,
mais qui fonctionne en corrigeant
ces inégalités,
tant au niveau des ressources
que de la démocratie ?
Est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose, là,
qui empêche
cette harmonie
africaine ?
-Vous savez,
dans les années 60,
on entendait que
l'Asie ne pourrait pas
se développer.
On entendait qu'elle allait
basculer dans la famine.
Je me souviens encore,
quand j'enseignais
dans mes jeunes années :
l'Inde et la Chine,
c'était ce qu'on appelait les PMA,
les pays les moins avancés.
Aujourd'hui, on parle
de la puissance chinoise
qui est en train de rivaliser
avec la puissance américaine.
En réalité, quand on regarde
le continent africain,
on se rend compte que
c'est un vieux socle géologique
qui présente l'intérêt
d'avoir aujourd'hui
à peu près toutes les ressources
dont le monde a besoin pour entamer
la nouvelle révolution digitale.
C'est vraiment
le continent le plus avancé,
à la fois
dans sa gestion de l'économie
et dans sa gestion
des ressources naturelles.
On sait bien que
les paysans africains sont
dans une stratégie
de minimisation des risques.
On sait bien à quel point ils ont,
depuis très longtemps,
mis au point des systèmes
pour faire face
aux aléas.
Le continent africain,
ce dont il souffre
- mais c'est aussi un atout -
c'est que la moitié
de la population
a moins de 15 ans.
Comment voulez-vous gérer
un pays
où la moitié de la population
a moins de 15 ans ?
En plus,
quand vous formez ces jeunes,
eh bien, ils partent.
En fait, vous formez
des gens extrêmement compétents
qui deviennent médecins,
ingénieurs, agronomes
dans le reste du monde.
C'est l'exode des cerveaux.
On a, aujourd'hui,
une sorte - comment dire -
de recul qui fait
qu'on a l'impression
que l'Afrique est
très difficile à développer.
Ma conviction, c'est que,
dans 30 ans, on regardera ça,
en se disant :
"Et dire qu'on pensait
que l'Afrique
"ne se développerait jamais..."
En réalité,
qu'il s'agisse
des personnes âgées
qui ne sont pas livrées
à elles-mêmes,
des mécanismes de solidarité,
des mécanismes de résistance
et de résilience
face aux chocs climatiques,
de la capacité
à adopter très vite
l'innovation,
dans ce qu'on appelle
le saut de grenouille,
on a l'impression qu'il suffit
qu'il y ait un déclic...
On le voit dans certains pays,
parce que certains pays sont
très, très avancés.
Malheureusement,
ce sont plutôt
des pays où les dirigeants
sont un peu autoritaires,
mais nous avons aussi
des démocraties très avancées.
Pour moi,
le jour où l'Afrique apprendra
à gérer intelligemment
tous ces gens qui veulent
tirer parti de ses richesses,
en faisant jouer
les concurrences et les convoitises
chinoises, indiennes,
turques, israéliennes,
françaises, anglaises,
américaines,
comme le font déjà certains pays,
elle deviendra
la première puissance mondiale,
car elle aura la jeunesse,
la démographie,
les matières premières
et la capacité à gérer la nature.
-Venons-en à des questions
sécuritaires et stratégiques
avec vous,
Antoine Glaser.
La France poursuit
son désengagement
militaire de l'Afrique.
Des puissances émergentes
s'y installent
et se payent
en ressources minières
et autres prédations foncières.
Qu'est-ce que
vous pensez
de ces nouveaux profiteurs ?
-Les nouveaux profiteurs...
On pense aux Russes de Wagner
ou autres.
C'est bien évident
qu'il y a des profiteurs,
mais ils profitent
sur un système,
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas eux
qui créent les problèmes.
Ils profitent d'un système ancien.
C'est une sorte
d'anachronisme historique,
parce qu'ils vont être là
dans des secteurs...
Par exemple, je pense que
la France a eu tort de se retirer
de la Centrafrique
avec l'opération Sangaris,
parce qu'ils ont sous-estimé
à quel point
la Centrafrique était un pays
totalement géostratégique,
compte tenu de ses frontières,
compte tenu du fait que
c'est un pays
où il y a des diamants.
Ca veut dire que
Wagner se paye sur les diamants,
en particulier.
Une poignée de diamants,
si vous allez...
Un copain y était allé.
Vous prenez
une poignée de diamants
et vous avez 100 millions de dollars
dans la main.
Avec ça, Wagner peut se payer
des mercenaires.
La France a laissé tomber
la Centrafrique,
à tel point que
ce sont les Américains
qui veulent venir chasser les Russes
de Centrafrique.
La France
en a été chassée,
effectivement, mais à mon avis,
c'était une période historique.
C'était une période décoloniale.
On était beaucoup trop présent
pendant une période trop longue.
Je veux dire que
c'est l'histoire qui parle.
Il faut
vraiment penser
que ce continent est devenu...
L'Afrique s'est mondialisée
sans qu'on s'en rende compte.
On regardait la réunification
de l'Allemagne.
On voyait pas du tout
l'Afrique se mondialiser.
Je me souviens,
dans les milieux patronaux,
les mecs disaient
"Les Chinois auront besoin
de nous", etc.
C'est une période historique.
Très honnêtement,
sur ce continent,
il faut faire confiance aux gens
qui sont à la manoeuvre.
S'il y a des autocrates,
ils se débrouilleront,
mais les Russes surfent
sur des situations anciennes,
sur des anachronismes,
sur le refoulé,
mais il faut parler de l'histoire,
de cette période particulière.
-Calixthe Beyala,
il ne s'agit pas
d'avoir des questions qui fâchent,
mais il s'agit
d'avancer.
On parle
de profiteurs.
C'est le thème de l'émission.
La Russie, la Chine, la Turquie...
Plein de pays sont là.
Ils sont là
pour leurs propres intérêts,
comme l'était la Françafrique.
A votre avis,
l'expérience
que vous avez de l'Afrique
suffit-elle à empêcher
ces nouveaux profiteurs
de piller l'Afrique ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
pour ne pas les laisser
libres
de cette prédation ?
Tous les pays sont prédateurs.
Il n'y a pas que l'Europe,
dans ce domaine-là.
-Je pense que
vous sous-estimez beaucoup
les Africains.
Ca me gêne vraiment.
Ca me gêne, parce que
nous sommes des êtres humains.
Nous avons une expérience
de la prédation.
On ne va pas quitter la Françafrique
pour tomber aux mains des Russes.
Vous pensez qu'on est là,
parce que nous les adorons ?
On ne les connaît même pas.
Je ne parle pas
le russe.
Il y a peut-être quelques Africains
qui parlent le russe.
On ne les connaît pas,
mais on a eu besoin d'eux
pour des situations
bien précises
de terrorisme.
Vous pensez
qu'on va les laisser là ?
Mais vous vous gourez !
Aucun Africain
ne va laisser...
On ne va plus laisser
quelqu'un rester là et nous piller.
On ne va pas non plus se couper
du reste du monde.
On aura toujours des partenaires,
dont les Russes,
les Français, les Américains,
les Chinois, etc.,
mais arrêtez de nous prendre
- c'est ce qui me gêne,
dans ce débat -
pour des gens...
Des enfants qu'on pille,
qu'on torpille,
qu'on doit aider, que ceci...
On a grandi.
Ce que j'ai aimé
dans ce que vient de dire mon ami,
tout à l'heure,
c'est que vous n'avez pas vu
l'Afrique
se mondialiser.
Vous ne l'avez pas vue grandir.
Sinon, vous ne me poseriez pas
ce genre de questions.
On utilise les autres
comme ils nous utilisent
et on va les mettre
dehors.
S'ils nous dérangent,
on mettra les Russes dehors,
comme avec la Françafrique.
On est en train d'essayer
de casser tout ça.
Faites-nous confiance.
Je tiens à dire quelque chose.
Excusez-moi.
Beaucoup d'Africains
ne quittent pas l'Afrique.
Ca, c'est une idée reçue.
Il y a à peine
0,2 % d'Africains
qui quittent
l'Afrique.
-Il y a plus de médecins béninois
en France qu'au Bénin.
C'est ça, le problème.
C'est qu'on s'est embêté
à former des gens brillants
qui partent.
-Non.
Tous les gens brillants
ne partent pas.
0,2 % seulement d'Africains
quittent le continent.
La plupart
de l'immigration africaine
se fait à l'intérieur du continent.
-Je sais bien,
mais...
-Les médecins camerounais
vont travailler au Gabon,
plus qu'en France.
Si, si.
Ils vont travailler au Gabon
où ils seront mieux payés,
en Afrique du Sud.
L'immigration africaine
est d'abord interafricaine.
En même temps, les hommes
se sont toujours déplacés.
Il y a aussi des médecins français
en Afrique, aux Etats-Unis.
Vous n'allez pas empêcher
le monde d'être le monde,
c'est-à-dire que
des hommes se rencontrent,
comme depuis la nuit des temps,
qu'ils échangent des idées
et des expériences.
Ca a toujours été comme ça.
-Sylvie Brunel,
il faut qu'on avance
un peu
dans cette émission.
Il y a une question économique
qui se pose.
On considère que
les ajustements structurels
- vous pourrez même expliquer
ce que ça veut dire -
du FMI,
de la Banque mondiale,
de l'OMC, etc.,
ont provoqué
des faillites socio-économiques,
pas qu'en Afrique.
On l'a vu aussi
en Amérique latine.
Est-ce que
vous considérez que
c'est encore vrai, aujourd'hui ?
-Alors, il faudrait rappeler
très, très rapidement
que l'Afrique est entrée
dans la crise de la dette
dans les années 1980-1990.
A la suite de cela,
elle a vu des cohortes
d'experts internationaux
lui prendre sa souveraineté
pour appliquer ce qu'on appelle
des programmes
d'ajustement structurel :
libéralisation,
ouverture des frontières,
privatisation
des entreprises publiques.
Parallèlement à cette ingérence
économique,
il y a eu une ingérence politique,
puisqu'on a conditionné
l'aide à la démocratisation,
sachant qu'un certain nombre
de chefs d'Etat
tenaient leur légitimité
de leurs soutiens extérieurs,
que ces soutiens viennent
du monde occidental
ou du monde soviétique.
Dans les années 1990-2000,
l'Afrique est entrée
dans ce que j'appelle
"la décennie du chaos".
Ces deux chocs extrêmement brutaux
ont provoqué un grand nombre
de guerres civiles
- 35 pays en guerre sur 53,
puisque le Soudan du Sud
n'existait pas encore -
face auxquelles nous avons répondu
d'abord par de l'humanitaire,
dans une logique
de "containment".
-Tout ça,
c'est de l'histoire,
mais aujourd'hui ?
-Oui,
mais pour comprendre aujourd'hui,
il faut mettre
un petit peu le nez
dans l'histoire.
Ensuite,
l'Afrique est entrée
dans une forte période
de croissance,
la période 2000-2010,
à peu près.
Il y a eu, en Occident,
la crise des subprimes.
Elle a pensé
qu'elle en serait exclue,
mais elle en a subi le rebond,
ce qui a provoqué
un certain nombre de crises.
Ensuite, il y a eu, de 2010 à 2020,
ce qu'on pourrait appeler
la période chinoise,
avec une Chine extrêmement présente
en Afrique,
investissant beaucoup,
et puis, des process
d'annulation de dettes de la part
des Européens, des Occidentaux,
se rendant compte
qu'ils avaient placé les Africains
dans des conditions
dont ils ne pouvaient pas sortir.
Ensuite, il y a eu
la pandémie de Covid.
Cette pandémie de Covid a eu
quelque chose de très surprenant :
on s'est rendu compte que
l'Afrique manifestait
une résilience extraordinaire.
Le reste du monde tombait
dans une espèce
d'hécatombe
et l'Afrique résistait.
-Oui, mais votre diagnostic,
aujourd'hui ?
-Oui.
Mon diagnostic,
aujourd'hui, c'est qu'il n'y a
jamais eu autant d'acteurs
étrangers
qui s'intéressent à l'Afrique
et qu'il n'y a jamais eu
autant d'opportunités
- comme l'a dit Calixthe -
pour les Africains,
de jouer
de ces concurrences
pour tirer leur épingle du jeu,
sachant que c'est eux
qui possèdent aujourd'hui
les richesses
que le monde entier convoite
pour pouvoir réussir
la transition écologique.
Ils ont toutes ces richesses.
Il s'agit juste
qu'ils en reprennent
la souveraineté.
-Aminata Traoré,
j'aimerais avoir
votre avis
sur cette question
des institutions financières
internationales :
le FMI,
la Banque mondiale.
Est-ce que vous considérez
que ces institutions,
aujourd'hui,
encore aujourd'hui,
empêchent,
j'allais dire,
des situations harmonieuses
en Afrique ?
-Oui, bien sûr.
Moi, je ne suis pas sûre,
comme Sylvie...
-Brunel.
-Comme Sylvie Brunel
le soutient,
que les choses vont si bien
dans certains pays.
La question fondamentale,
c'est ce que "développer" veut dire.
Qu'est-ce que
"développer" veut dire ?
Est-ce que
c'est des infrastructures,
des bâtiments qui poussent,
des investisseurs étrangers
qui viennent ?
Je n'en suis pas sûre.
Nos pays, nos Etats ont
les mêmes maîtres.
Ils ont les mêmes maîtres :
FMI, Banque mondiale, OMC,
Union européenne...
Ce sont les mêmes.
Nous nous inscrivons,
nous...
L'Afrique, aujourd'hui,
s'inscrit
dans une dynamique mondiale
qui relève de la guerre.
La mondialisation
néolibérale,
c'est la guerre.
C'est une guerre sans merci.
C'est elle, aujourd'hui,
qui est...
Aujourd'hui,
la guerre russo-ukrainienne,
l'OTAN...
Nous ne sommes...
L'Afrique ne fonctionne pas
en dehors de ces réalités.
L'OTAN s'occupe aujourd'hui
du Sahel.
Pourquoi on s'étonne que...
Au début de cette guerre,
il y a 10 ans, j'ai dit
que c'était pas notre guerre.
Aujourd'hui, les Africains disent
que ce n'est pas notre guerre.
Je suis de ceux qui, dès 2013,
ont dit : "Cette guerre
"soi-disant anti-djihadistes
n'est pas notre guerre."
Les djihadistes que je connais,
que je vois, aujourd'hui,
qui sèment la terreur
dans les villages, qui tuent,
sont des victimes des programmes
d'ajustement structurel.
On peut pas dire
que c'était une autre histoire.
C'est la même histoire.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Souvenez-vous.
La grande...
Disons...
La Banque mondiale ne jurait
que par la lutte
contre la pauvreté.
C'est devenu, aujourd'hui...
Ca s'est transformé
en une lutte contre les pauvres,
parce que les projets mis en oeuvre
profitent d'abord à d'autres,
à une poignée d'Africains initiés
qui savent...
-Mais Mme Traoré, Mme Traoré,
l'assujettissement
économique,
c'est pas la relation
de maître à esclave
d'il y a plusieurs siècles.
Les pays sont indépendants,
aujourd'hui, alors...
-Les pays...
Les acteurs sont les mêmes.
J'ai entendu dire,
dans le cadre
de l'intervention militaire
de la France
au Mali que c'est un devoir
de civilisation.
Et c'est ce que j'entends
aujourd'hui
dans le cadre
de la guerre russo-ukrainienne
ou plutôt de l'Occident
contre la Russie ou vice versa,
j'en sais rien. Ce que je sais,
c'est que rien n'a changé
et c'est notre grille de lecture,
c'est le diagnostic qui me paraît
aujourd'hui totalement erroné.
Vous pouvez pas
comprendre l'Afrique
sans l'inscrire
dans ce système global
et dans cette levée de boucliers
des peuples du monde.
Il n'y a pas qu'ici. Les peuples
du monde aujourd'hui disent non
à la dictature du marché.
-Calixthe Beyala, vous vouliez
intervenir sur la question
des institutions financières
par rapport à ce qui a été dit.
-J'épouse tout ce qui a été dit
par rapport aux institutions
financières n'étant pas économiste.
Je me souviens
de cet ajustement structurel
qui avait mis le Cameroun K.-O.
Mes oncles se sont retrouvés au
chômage, je devais me débrouiller,
j'étais toute jeune, à Paris,
pour leur envoyer de quoi manger.
Mais sachez aussi
que, au-delà du FMI et tout ça,
les gouvernements,
notamment du Cameroun,
vont profiter
de l'ajustement structurel
pour dominer les populations.
Comment ?
A savoir que ces ajustements
structurels ont pris fin
dans les années 2000, d'accord.
Au Cameroun, les salaires avaient
été divisés par 3.
Aujourd'hui,
alors que la plupart des pays
ont remis les salaires en place,
le Cameroun ne l'a pas fait.
Ce qui veut dire que
on a un salaire 3 fois moindre
que, par exemple,
au Gabon ou en Centrafrique
et dans d'autres pays africains.
C'est fait exprès
pour mieux écraser les peuples,
pour mieux les dominer.
-Mais comment vous pouvez dire
des choses pareilles
quand on voit que ces 50 dernières
années, l'Afrique a
considérablement progressé
en espérance
de vie, en politique d'éducation,
de santé, etc. ?
Est-ce que c'est pas
exagéré que de dire
que ces institutions sont venues
écraser ?
-Vous oubliez aussi une chose,
c'est la capacité d'inventivité,
de créativité du peuple africain.
Nous avons nous-mêmes
avec nos petits moyens
construit des petites écoles
dans les villages,
construit des petits dispensaires,
remis en place
les méthodes traditionnelles
de soins.
Notre pharmacopée aujourd'hui
est plus valide que jamais.
Vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
de la Covid-19.
Nous n'avons pas attendu
les vaccins pour soigner
nos malades de Covid. On a
récupéré
nos médicaments traditionnels.
J'y étais.
Donc tout ce qui était
méprisé autrefois a été
réhabilité. Ne pensez pas
que nous sommes là,
on attend qu'on nous apporte
ce qu'il faut.
On bâtit nos universités
aujourd'hui, des universités
panafricaines
avec d'autres modes de réflexion,
d'autres façons d'enseigner aussi.
Dans un pays comme le Cameroun,
c'est un peuple extrêmement
dynamique, qui crée
des universités. On n'attend pas
les aides. On sait que quelquefois,
c'est un poison
et que, souvent, c'était
une manière de nous inféoder
et de nous dominer.
Nous en sommes conscients.
Moi, je suis une enfant d'après
les indépendances.
Ce n'est pas pareil
que nos parents qui sont nés
avant les indépendances.
On a une autre façon
de regarder le monde.
Nous faisons partie du monde
et nous allons le conquérir.
Je suis très confiante sur le fait
que, dans 30 ans,
comme disait Sylvie,
notre pays, notre continent
sera la terre d'accueil
de tous les autres peuples
du monde.
-Antoine Glaser, votre point de vue
sur cette question
des institutions.
C'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup critiqué le FMI,
la Banque mondiale.
Quand des pays sont en difficulté,
ils exigent des ajustements
qui ont des conséquences.
Mais vous avez le sentiment
que tout ce qui a été distribué
comme aide au développement
à travers ces institutions n'a eu
que des effets négatifs ?
-Je suis incapable
de me prononcer sur le fond.
Je suis pas économiste. Simplement,
ce que je peux dire, c'est que,
de la même façon que la France
a exporté dans ces pays
toutes ses institutions, etc.,
ce qui permet
que les chefs d'Etat y sont devenus
des vrais constitutionnalistes.
Ca leur permet de faire
des 2e, 3e, 4e mandats.
Mais surtout,
ce que je crois par contre,
c'est que ces grandes institutions
de Bretton Woods, FMI,
Banque mondiale,
ça leur a permis de faire
vivre des dizaines
de milliers d'experts. Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils envoyaient avec les
programmes d'ajustement structurel,
autour de ce qui était imposé
d'une façon ou d'une autre,
il y a bien évidemment...
mais vraiment,
moi, j'ai connu dans les hôtels,
des hôtels en Afrique
qui étaient bourrés d'experts.
C'était comme si c'était
une autre langue,
le FMI et la Banque mondiale.
C'était la langue des économistes
que les Africains, fallait surtout
pas leur apprendre cette langue.
C'est des experts qui étaient
autour des conseillers,
autour de tous les ministres, etc.
C'est ça,
la domination aussi. Moi,
je me prononce pas, je sais pas
ce qu'ils ont apporté,
ce qu'ils ont retiré,
mais je peux vous dire que vraiment
ça a fait vivre l'extérieur.
Il y a la même chose,
on va en parler
sans doute avec Sylvie,
sur les ONG. Pourquoi,
par exemple, de l'extérieur,
on donne jamais à des ONG locales,
on donne toujours
à des ONG de l'extérieur ?
Je vais pas citer l'agence
ou d'autres, qui disent toujours,
on peut pas, on est banquiers.
En tant que banquiers, on peut pas
donner à une ONG locale.
Tout ça, c'est ça qui crée aussi
ce sentiment de dépossession
de l'Afrique par rapport
à ces grandes institutions.
Ca veut pas dire qu'à l'intérieur
de la Banque mondiale ou du FMI,
ils ont intégré
énormément de jeunes Africains.
On parle de ces grandes
institutions, Sylvie Brunel, mais
certaines ONG sont en elles-mêmes
de grandes institutions.
Pour ne pas les citer,
par exemple, OXFAM a des moyens
considérables. Quel bilan
vous faites
de cette action des ONG,
disons des principales ONG,
en Afrique ? Le bilan, il est
contrasté, il est positif ?
-Vous savez, Emile, il y a
un proverbe en Afrique qui dit :
"La main qui donne est toujours
au-dessus de la main qui reçoit."
Vous avez donc
une prolifération d'institutions
qui prétendent toutes
sauver l'Afrique malgré elle.
Vous savez que le développement,
c'est avoir la capacité de choix,
être souverain
quand on est face à son destin.
Que constate-t-on ?
Que, dans le domaine
de l'humanitaire,
tout un ensemble d'acteurs
prétendent à leur niveau
savoir mieux que le paysan africain
ce qui est bon pour son avenir.
Que, dans l'environnement,
et Calixthe y a fait allusion,
on crée des zones protégées,
mais protégées
contre l'éleveur africain,
contre le paysan africain.
Avec la complicité
des autorités locales.
On constate aussi que, chaque fois
que l'on reçoit un prêt,
alors, vous savez que l'Europe
a largement aujourd'hui
annulé sa dette et délié
son aide, c'est-à-dire
qu'elle ne conditionne plus
son aide
à l'achat de biens et de services
en provenance de l'Europe,
mais ce n'est pas le cas
de la Chine,
qui, d'une façon
beaucoup plus cynique, exige
pour pouvoir construire
des infrastructures,
avoir accès aux ports,
mettre en place
des mécanismes de coopération,
d'avoir la mainmise sur
les matières premières africaines,
qui crée aussi des systèmes
complètement fermés
où elle n'emploie pas
les Africains.
Il y a très peu de mariages qu'on
pourrait appeler "inter-raciaux",
même si ça ne veut rien dire.
Donc on se rend compte que
l'Afrique est envahie d'acteurs
aux motivations
plus ou moins troubles,
qu'elle a beaucoup de mal
à coordonner, qu'elle a beaucoup
de mal surtout à dominer
si je puis dire.
Et je pense
qu'il faut qu'elle reprenne
en ce domaine sa souveraineté.
Pour ça, il ne faut plus
qu'elle demande d'aide
de l'extérieur, parce qu'elle a
elle-même les moyens sur place
avec toutes ses matières premières,
tous ses atouts, de transformer
sur place en créant
un marché intérieur,
un processus de développement
qui la rendrait
comme les pays d'Asie,
comme la Chine, comme les émergents
de l'Asie de l'Est, totalement
souveraine quant à son avenir.
Pour revenir
à ce que disait Calixthe,
je pense qu'on peut très bien avoir
dans 30 ans un renversement total
de l'histoire de l'humanité
avec une Afrique,
où un humain sur quatre
sera effectivement africain,
et qui donnera le la
au reste du monde
sur la gestion des personnes âgées,
sur la gestion de la nature,
sur la gestion de l'énergie,
sur la gestion aussi
d'un développement qui sait saisir
le meilleur des technologies.
-Alors, puisqu'on est bientôt
à la fin de cette émission
et qu'on parle
de grande transformation,
Madame Traoré, vous êtes
avec nous depuis Bamako,
je voudrais vous poser une question
qui fait partie
de vos préoccupations politiques
au niveau de l'écologie.
La prise de conscience
du réchauffement climatique,
elle est acquise partout.
En Afrique comme ailleurs.
Les politiques économiques
ne suivent pas toujours,
notamment en matière
de coopération,
de commerce extérieur,
de transition énergétique.
Qu'est-ce qui empêche
à votre avis l'Afrique
d'avoir aujourd'hui
une politique écologique
qui tienne compte à la fois
des traditions et de la modernité ?
-C'est pour ça
que je m'interroge encore une fois.
J'ai l'impression...
Notre débat va dans le sens de...
Même si on n'idéalise pas
le développement,
c'est comme s'il y a un modèle
performant et vertueux
quelque part,
l'Afrique n'y est pas
et elle va certainement
y arriver comme les autres. Mais
moi, je n'envie pas les autres.
Quand je vois
l'état du monde aujourd'hui,
je n'envie pas les autres.
-C'est vrai.
-C'est à nous, à la lumière
de l'état catastrophique
de la planète,
c'est à nous de nous dire,
ils prétendent avoir décollé,
ils sont partis,
mais nous voici au même endroit.
Quand je regarde
la bagarre pour les retraites,
et les tremblements de terre,
les migrants,
on a tellement de problèmes !
Calixthe a raison de dire
que c'est humain.
On a devant nous
une somme considérable
de situations
qui ne permet pas d'être
optimiste, en disant :
on va y arriver comme les autres.
Mais j'ai pas envie d'y arriver
comme les autres, les autres
n'y sont pas. Ils n'y sont pas
précisément parce que leur modèle,
le modèle dont on parle,
c'est le même modèle.
Nous, on n'a pas
eu le temps de penser,
d'avoir une pensée économique et
politique qui devait nous mettre
à l'abri de cette situation.
C'est parce que les autres savent,
ceux qui sont partis, les sociétés,
les nations esclavagistes
et colonialistes
qui sont sorties par la fenêtre,
qui reviennent par la porte,
qui disent "les autres"
quand ils parlent de la Russie,
de la Chine et de la Turquie.
Ils disent "les compétiteurs",
"les concurrents".
Ce qui veut dire quoi ?
Que l'Afrique est une proie.
L'Afrique est une proie,
donc les gagnants de ce système,
ceux qui ont cru qu'ils gagnaient,
se bousculent,
veulent occuper le terrain
pour que les autres
ne viennent pas.
Et nous, Africains,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
On va être là
en train de dire : venez,
il y a les terres, il y a les
ressources et allons-y.
Nous voulons développer comme vous,
mais moi, j'ai pas envie
de me développer comme eux,
d'autant plus que notre continent,
on est un dépotoir.
Les déchets.
Je ne vois que des déchets.
Je me suis battue toute ma vie
pour les textiles africains,
mais je ne vois
que la friperie, partout.
De Nairobi à Dakar.
La plupart des boutiques,
nos jeunes ne vendent
que des restes.
-En somme,
vous êtes en train de dire
que l'écologie est
une chance pour l'Afrique ?
-Bien sûr.
-Elle pourrait être une chance,
pourvu que ce soit pas le modèle
capitaliste destructeur,
congénitalement destructeur.
Des humains, de la cohésion sociale
et du vivant.
-Ce qui n'empêche pas
qu'il y ait du capitalisme
dans les pays africains
et ailleurs.
Un mot là-dessus
et on a terminé, Calixthe Beyala.
-Oui...
-Sur l'écologie comme une chance.
-L'Afrique n'a pas eu besoin du
mot écologie pour être écologiste.
Le peuple africain
autrefois, naturellement,
ne prenait dans la nature
que ce dont il avait besoin.
On ne prenait jamais plus.
Je me souviens
quand j'étais enfant de mes oncles,
quand ils allaient à la chasse,
ils ramenaient un gibier,
pas parce
qu'ils en avaient pas trouvé,
mais un. D'ailleurs,
ils me demandaient le matin :
"Qu'est-ce que tu veux manger
aujourd'hui ?"
Je disais : "Je veux une biche."
Et ils amenaient une biche
pour tout le village,
mais pas dix biches.
Donc on n'a pas eu besoin de
l'Occident pour pouvoir savoir
ce qu'il faut faire pour vivre
en cohésion avec la nature.
Ca, c'est le 1er point.
Le 2e point,
c'est que, effectivement,
comme le disait
Aminata, on a eu...
Nous sommes devenus un dépotoir
avec les vieilles voitures,
la friperie, les vieux frigos,
les vieilles télévisions, tout
ce dont l'Occident n'a pas besoin.
Ils mettent ça dans les bateaux
et jettent ça chez nous
et ça nous pollue.
Donc nous allons faire un travail,
et moi, je suis confiante
là-dessus, pour balayer
tout cela, réapprendre aux gens,
comme nos parents le faisaient
autrefois, à marcher à pied.
On faisait 20 kilomètres
pour aller à l'école.
Les jeunes Africains ont oublié ça.
On va repartir vers un autre type
de développement.
On ne va pas rejeter
ce qu'il y a de bon en Occident,
on va prendre
ce que vous avez de bon
et on va faire
à notre façon pour ne pas avoir
ce que vous avez produit de mal.
C'est la chance que nous avons.
Je suis contre ceux qui disent
de rejeter l'Occident.
Il y a de très belles choses
et nous allons les prendre.
Le système de retraite,
je trouve ça très bien et on va
les appliquer
ou les lois sur le travail,
il faudrait peut-être
qu'on s'inspire
de ça et que les travailleurs
soient plus protégés.
La Sécurité sociale, j'aimerais
bien qu'on ait ça chez nous.
Mais il y a des choses
que je n'aimerais pas,
le développement
à tout prix, les immeubles partout,
parce que l'humain n'a pas besoin
de tant de richesses,
de tant d'argent pour survivre.
Nous allons refuser cet aspect-là.
-Merci.
L'émission se termine là-dessus,
donc sur une Afrique
qui serait et qui est,
comme vous l'avez dit,
en phase
avec ce développement durable
et contre tous les gaspillages.
Il me reste à vous présenter
une bibliographie.
Aminata Traoré, vous avez publié
il y a quelques années
"L'étau. L'Afrique
dans un monde sans frontières".
Vous n'avez pas changé
d'avis aujourd'hui ?
-Non.
Rires
-Vous pensez que
l'étau est toujours là ?
-Qu'il se resserre,
mais on va se battre.
-Bien.
Alors, je voudrais signaler
le livre d'Eric Toussaint,
"Banque mondiale,
une histoire critique".
C'est un livre
qui est plein d'informations
sur les relations
dont on a parlé entre l'Afrique
et les grandes institutions
et tous ces ajustements
structurels qui ont provoqué,
comme ça a été dit
au cours de cette émission
de nombreux dégâts.
Alors, Antoine Glaser, vous avez
publié il y a
quelques années
avec Stephen Smith
"L'Afrique sans Africains".
-"Le rêve blanc du continent noir".
Et votre livre,
"Le piège africain de Macron",
vient d'être publié chez Pluriel.
Quelle continuité il y a
entre tous ces livres
sur l'Afrique ?
C'est une mission chez vous ?
-Non, c'est pas une mission.
Mais c'est vrai que,
quand j'entends Aminata
parler d'Afrique dépotoir,
ça me fait bondir.
Je vais pas être critique
sur le voyage
du Président Macron au Gabon,
mais avant de dire
que les grandes forêts du Gabon,
c'est le bien commun de l'humanité,
comme si ça appartenait pas
aux Africains,
les biens communs de tous,
il faut pas y toucher,
qu'on s'occupe déjà
de l'Afrique dépotoir !
-Un mot quand même. Quand on dit
que les forêts sont des biens,
c'est dans la mesure
où ils capturent le gaz carbonique.
-Oui, mais
on dit que c'est les biens communs
de l'humanité. OK, mais à part ça,
l'Afrique finalement
a été très vertueuse
par rapport à l'ensemble du monde
sur la pollution du monde
et on va dire :
touchez surtout pas à vos forêts,
ça peut servir à tout le monde. OK.
C'est là où il y a
un vrai problème.
-Bien. Calixthe
Beyala, vous avez publié
il y a quelques années
"Les honneurs perdus".
-Ou "Le Christ selon l'Afrique",
le plus récent.
-Ou "Le Christ selon l'Afrique".
Tout ça, vous restez finalement
dans ce lignage africain
quand vous écrivez ?
C'est l'Afrique qui écrit en vous
ou finalement, maintenant, comme
vous vivez également en France,
est-ce que c'est le monde
qui vous motive ?
-Il y a l'Afrique
qui me motive certes,
mais en même temps,
j'appartiens au monde.
Je crois plus en l'identité
géographique des peuples
qu'en l'identité raciale.
Vous prenez un petit Européen,
vous le mettez en Afrique,
pour moi, c'est un Africain,
parce que l'environnement
dans lequel il vit
va faire de lui ce qu'il est.
Donc ce que je suis,
c'est un mélange
de l'Afrique et de l'Europe.
Et personne ne peut me le dénier.
Mes enfants sont pareils.
Chaque être humain aujourd'hui
dépend de son environnement.
C'est pour ça que ceux qui parlent
de grand remplacement
et toutes ces conneries,
j'appelle ça vraiment...
-Ce n'est pas au coeur
de notre émission.
Donc ignorons
cet extrémisme-là.
-Ca fait partie,
c'est pour dire que nous sommes
tout cela à la fois.
-Bien entendu.
Sylvie Brunel, vous venez
de publier "Nourrir.
Cessons de maltraiter
"ceux qui nous font vivre !".
Nous aurons l'occasion de parler
des paysans, de l'agriculture,
mais pourquoi avoir
publié ce cri aujourd'hui ?
-Bah parce que, dans le monde
entier, on n'a jamais autant parlé
de l'arme alimentaire,
de l'insécurité alimentaire,
qu'il y a dans le monde entier
plus de 1,3 milliard de paysans
qui travaillent dur,
qui nous nourrissent
et que, dans tous les pays,
ils sont méprisés,
ils sont critiqués,
alors que tous les enjeux
aujourd'hui, écologiques,
énergétiques,
paysagers, patrimoniaux
et bien sûr nourriciers,
passent par eux,
parce qu'ils
travaillent avec le vivant.
Et c'est particulièrement vrai
que le continent africain,
où les mégalopoles sont extrêmement
importatrices de nourriture,
alors qu'on a encore plus
de la moitié de la population
qui travaille dans les campagnes.
-Donc vous considérez aujourd'hui
que l'alimentation est
sacrifiée au profit
de la grosse industrialisation
et du capitalisme international ?
-Non, je considère
que la souveraineté alimentaire
est une question essentielle
qui est revenue au 1er plan
avec la pandémie,
la guerre en Ukraine, l'inflation,
le fait que les exportations
de la Russie et de l'Ukraine
ont été bloquées
pendant très longtemps,
alors que la Russie est
aujourd'hui le 1er
producteur de blé au monde
et que nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui, dans ce monde
de plus en plus urbain,
de reconsidérer ces gens
dans les campagnes qui triment
dur, comme l'a dit Calixthe,
qui élèvent
des bêtes et qui sont
souvent considérés
comme la dernière roue du carrosse.
-Merci pour cet éloge mérité
de la paysannerie
et du monde agricole.
Il me reste
à vous remercier, Mesdames,
cher Antoine Glaser.
Je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP, qui a permis donc
la réalisation de cette émission.
Et avant de nous quitter,
je vous laisse
avec cette citation
de Nicolas Baverez :
"L'Afrique a
considérablement changé
"depuis la fin du XXe siècle,
"elle participe à la naissance
d'un Sud global."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
...